We purchased it in for its son a there a size portable. What temperature and length of time do you recommend a person start at?
I recommend you started a hundred and forty degrees and that you just start with like five minutes
It and some people can't even tolerate five minutes if you're like, oh, this is a piece of cake
Well, you could push it a little bit, but you can you don't want to like be exhausted the rest of the day
So because that can be you know, not uncommon when a person starts doing the son if you've ever done a son of before
You can we always feel so good, and then you're like just waste of the rest of the day
So you just be careful of that. So I'd say start five to ten minutes maximum and ultimately you want to get do it for
20 to 30 minutes maximum person everybody's a little bit different some people could do 30 minutes on us
No big deal. No problem to me. It's like I
When I don't do son is at this time of the year in the winter I'll do son is again and I tend to not go more than 20 minutes
And I tend I do not go more than hundred and forty degrees